I generally find myself terrifically
excited about where we're headed I mean
I know there's a lot of doom and gloom
out there about you can't get
independent films finance the way you
used to and that is true you used to be
able to take a movie to Sundance in 1995
and if it was decent you made five
million dollars on it now you're lucky
to make your money back this is true
there's too much TV out there well I
like how is this not going to get
devalued I think it is but for our
personalities and who we are it is
putting the onus and the responsibility
squarely into our laps our destinies are
our own and I think we're headed towards
a place where ownership is going to be
paramount like owning your own content
and so I think for the people who are
willing to slowly brick by brick build
their own empires starting from a short
film that's three dollars to the fifty
dollar short film to that five thousand
dollar movie that they then make and
then the fifty thousand dollar movie
that is made from the profits of that
and then you can turn around ten years
later and you own 15 things and you get
to resell them or maybe even create your
own channel based upon that this is the
best time in the world for self starters
so that to me is is great we can be more
misanthropic and just go right into our
own little world and and do what we do
yeah I mean the most exciting thing to
me in the world right now is that if you
own a 5d and a boom microphone you can
shoot a feature film on weekends for two
thousand dollars or less or less and I
am like kind of upset then I don't have
the time to do it because we have an HBO
show and I have two beautiful healthy
children that is where i'm at right now
but i am not kidding that like weirdly
that I mean it kills me when I hear
people complaining about anything
because you're only the only in this is
the scariest part in the best part the
only limit to you making a great movie
is your own creativity and
annuity that's it now